the reddit discussion forum is more
active than ever it is stunning what is
going on at david pakman.com slash
reddit where our viewers and listeners
can communicate with each other and also
with us pat checks the reddit regularly
I am on the reddit regularly I wanted to
go through some of the popular
discussions on the reddit discussion
forum as of this morning starting with a
discussion about why we shouldn't have
to make this argument but that it is
still important to explain that the
Nazis were not actually socialists
there's this very a common talking point
from some who are on the right who say
hey socialists Nazi stood for National
Socialists there's no difference between
a Nazi and someone like Bernie Sanders
and of course it's sad that we have to
explain it but the Nazis were not
socialists in any reasonable sense of
the word very interesting discussion on
our reddit discussion forum also there
have you ever changed someone's mind
about something political this is an
interesting discussion for a thread
about you know there's all this argument
and debate and conversation about
politics people with different political
views our people's minds ever actually
changed like have you ever changed
someone else's mine because of an
argument that you made has your mind
ever been changed by an argument that
somebody else made for you and I
actually think that the answer is yes I
don't think that the strategy for
Democrats in 2018 and 2020 should be to
talk Trump's voters into voting for
Democrats just work on voter turnout but
that's a separate question from whether
people's minds are changed based on
political debate and I think that they
are it depends I think on how
passionately someone speaks about the
issue as well because if they go into an
exchange super-passionate even if they
lose the argument they're not going to
admit that on the spot they may say they
had an evolution on their opinion
sometimes we can say they change their
mind sometimes you'll see people become
more planted in their beliefs when they
have passionate arguments against them
sure that's another thing that happens I
mean I think that the best case scenario
is someone understanding that they may
not understand all sides of the issue
and if you just come out with more
knowledge than they're able to take in
I think that's the best way for them to
become convinced there I don't know that
I agree I actually think the best way to
get somebody who might lack knowledge in
other words many people hold political
beliefs because of lack of knowledge
about the facts so to speak and
sometimes we think hey if we just hammer
them over the head with facts they'll
change their mind that's when I think
it's better to apply a basic Socratic
method of questioning how did you come
up with that interesting and go down
that path to a possibility make them
question where they came up with this
idea but anyway really good discussion
on reddit also from our reddit
discussion forum
the most common right wing troll
comments this is a really funny thread
where you hear people were listing what
they're a popular or the right-wing
troll Internet comments that they see
most often are and there's some really
good ones about Colin Kaepernick as a
thug is a good one the Civil War wasn't
about slavery it was about states rights
it's really like an encyclopedia entry
on the most common right wing talking
points that you see in internet
discussions I feel like this could be an
online generator where you just add in
the topic that you want a right-wing
troll to talk about and it would have in
the format yeah in the poor grammar and
everything else will come along with it
and lastly from our reddit discussion
forum a shame on you David how can you
number one not have watched an episode
of Game of Thrones and number two admit
on the screen that you haven't watched
an episode of Game of Thrones it's the
walk of shame for you shame shame shame
yeah I've seen 15 minutes of one episode
of Game of Thrones five years ago on an
airplane and then I fell asleep yeah I
have to admit something too I actually
don't watch Game of Thrones either I've
seen the majority of the first episode I
understand maybe people got the
impression that I watched it all I knew
is that there's a lot of turnover in
characters and yeah it was the point
that I made
I told I'm not really a fan myself
either I told ya I told some of my
family members in Argentina yeah I'm not
watching it and they said you know it's
international an international
phenomenon right and I said yeah I'm
aware of it I mean I'm aware of the
program I just haven't I don't have HBO
that's a starting point where I'm
operating from I'm sure I would get into
it even though fantasy is not really my
johner because just about everyone else
is and it's really a cultural experience
to learn
the reason why you have to join in no it
would be deep deep anthropology as a
result of watching it for sure alright
over 4000 of our viewers and listeners
now at david pakman.com slash read it
participating in a very polite political
conversation i encourage you to join us